want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carl michael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only wayne dyer
have a mind that is open to everything
and attached to nothing
one of the central principles of my life
is that no one knows enough
to be a pessimist
about anything
and that each and every one of us
when we close our mind
to what is possible for us or what is
possible for humanity
closes off
the genius
that resides and lives in each and every
one of us
having an open mind doesn't necessarily
mean
finding fault with all of the things
that you've been taught by others it
means
opening yourself up
to the potentiality and the possibility
that anything and everything is possible
so having a mind that is open to
everything
and attached to nothing
really means finding within ourselves
the ability to get rid of a trait that i
find so common
in contemporary
in the contemporary world
do you know that most people that i meet
spend their lives
looking
for occasions
to be offended
they actually are up out there hoping
that they can find some reason to be
offended and there's no shortage of
reasons they're out there everywhere the
way this person dressed the what the
worst person said they turn on their tv
they hear the news they're offended by
this someone didn't uh someone used
language that they didn't like someone
doesn't share the same customs that you
and people all day long in fact if you
keep track tomorrow you will find
uh probably
100 reasons that you can go around being
offended
but a mind that is open to everything
and attached to nothing is a mind that
says i'm never looking for anything to
be offended by
and that whatever anybody else out there
has to say my response to that is that's
an interesting point of view
i've never considered that before most
people are victims because of choice or
because of expectations people expect to
be victimized they think
they think they're not very strong and
they're not very capable or they they
don't have very high aspirations that's
if there's anything that i think people
suffer from in this country it's that
not that they fail to achieve so much is
that they fail to aspire they don't have
a sense of their own internal capacities
and greatness or abilities to handle
just about any situation we've talked
about that before but how can a book
tell you how to do this well a book
can't do it for you i'm the first one to
actually say that absolutely just like
going to a psychiatrist a psychiatrist
cannot make your life any better i'm
convinced of that nor can a valium or
anything like that it has to be
something that you do internally
yourself it can provide your guidelines
it's very much like if you your car
breaks down and you got your repair
manual there you say well why isn't this
manual fixing my car
manuals don't fix cars they can just
give you the information you either do
it to yourself or you don't but can the
book give you a way to rate yourself as
far as what how how victimized you you
really are yeah i i think so uh a lot of
people are very critical of books and
self-help books and whether or not they
can really be helpful to people and so
on i know in my own life i've been
really influenced by some very
significant writing of people who've
lived before me a lot of poets uh a lot
of the great you know even mark twain
reading people books have really
influenced my life these kinds of books
influence people's lives today i know it
from the mail that i get and uh well
what's step one
so after you've read the book step one
is to change your expectations around
like every situation you go into all
right you got who victimizes people the
most in our culture family members you
know your parents telling you that you
ought to be the way they want you to be
your uh your children telling you that
they expect you to make their lunches
for them they expect you to pick after
the up after them and so on uh
bureaucrats our government uh clerks
people like that waiters tipping when
you're getting bad service all of these
kinds of things you just change around
your expectations you say i am not going
to allow this person or this institution
to get me i'm not going to try to change
it for the whole world but wayne how
specifically i feel sorry for mothers
who are victimized every day i mean by
husbands and by kids you know they have
no they have no self left they give
everything and they but they've taught
themselves that they said to their
husbands or their children it's okay you
can push me around if you want to get uh
angry at me or upset at me then i'll
take that and i believe you get treated
in life the way you teach people to
treat you if you've taught people that
you're going to be a dishrag or you're
going to be somebody who's going to
clean up all the time and you're not
going to have any esteem for yourself
then naturally people are going to come
along and just do that but it's a desire
to be approved to be loved so now you're
saying no more mr nice guy i don't think
people are loved i think it's a myth
that you that you love dish rags or that
you love people i i think people respect
strength not weakness and you stand up
to somebody you say what's really on
your mind and at first people will feign
it you know they'll fake it they say oh
my god you've really hurt my feelings
that's a strategy that's a technique to
get you you know if i can get you to
come over and visit me on sunday by
using guilt you know and saying oh if
you don't visit me you know it's okay i
went through 18 hours of child labor but
that's okay if you don't come you know
and i can use all of this stuff and
you'll come well i'm going to continue
to use that but if you say wait a second
you know i've got a right to decide
where i'm going to be on sunday and i'm
i can't be there this sunday and you're
firm about that you know what happens is
after a while people respect you more
what happens at work though when you go
down and tell that to your boss
the very same thing i'm talking about it
you're fired
no
hardly ever and even if you are it's
generally for the better uh
even on the job people respect strength
you don't want somebody on the job who's
always going to be a yes man who's
always going to you know if you're
trying to run this show and you want to
know how things are going and what the
reactions are and you got a lot of yes
men around you which is like what nixon
had around him everybody's just going
around saying yes sir yes and you find
that the show's ratings are going down
and down and down because people aren't
being willing to be honest with you you
want to have a producer or director or
staff people who are going to say look
this is what you're doing that's not
working this is what's effective you
don't have to be nasty yeah but we
expect that but the question i have is
if you've set a pattern in your
household as a mother or even in a
relationship with a man or vice versa
and you've you've been the giver and the
nice guy all of a sudden when you make
that change then don't people pull back
and say wait you don't love me anymore
yeah they do and that's a technique too
that's a strategy to get you to go back
to uh being a slave again and when they
when you suddenly say to them i love you
it has nothing to do with love it has to
do with my
interest in being my own person and
you're you're using guilt saying you
know you don't love me isn't going to
work anymore how many women how many
times in your life have you gone out
with a man when you were dating or if
you're dating now uh have somebody
called you up and you know you don't
want to go out with this person you know
nice guy everything but you know there's
nothing there and you can't say no yeah
and you just say oh well and then there
there you are three weeks later you're
going out on a date and you're and this
guy is coming on to you and you're just
saying what am i doing here i know and
learning how to just say no you know i
don't want to go and he says well you
know you're hurting my feelings and i'll
probably have to put my head in the oven
and you know any number
all right all right i'll go i'll go you
know anything you know and this is the
you know that's a victim status you've
got to learn not to make commitments for
things and actually what you're saying
be a little selfish
selfish not inconsiderate yes but
selfish of definitely in your own time
yeah it's your life it's your time it's
the only shot you get at this life and
why should anybody else run it for you
seems like an awful lot of selfish
people in the world already well selfish
when you use selfish generally you mean
inconsiderate you know stepping on other
people not caring about others i don't
believe in that i don't do that myself i
spend most of my life in the service of
other people but it's because if you
love yourself you can you can give love
away if you if you can't give away what
you don't have if you don't okay that's
step one no more mr nice guy number two
it's like going out and practicing you
know uh really standing up for the
things you know somebody's out there
go practice being insulted
if it's necessary but but it isn't
necessary it's you know i have a thing
called being quietly effective john and
it's like you know
a lot of people misconstrue their goals
in life they pull into a gas station all
right and they want their windshield
washed the guy is too busy he doesn't
care he's not interested he doesn't wash
your windshield this person who wants
his windshield what forgets his goal is
just to have a windshield wash that's
all he now says i'm going to reform that
guy how dare he treat me that way who
does he think and he's going gonna and
this guy's behavior
is suddenly controlling them emotionally
and your goal is just to simply say look
would you mind washing my windshield you
don't have to give a lecture if the guy
says look i'm too busy they say well i'm
going to talk to the manager or whatever
you know you go on to the next step or
you get out and wash it yourself it's
necessary but you don't allow other
people's behavior to be the controlling
thing of your emotions in your life
whether that's that clerk there or
whether it's your husband or your
children well you said you said
something about explanation what about
people that feel like they've got to
give a long drawn-out explanation with a
thousand reasons and excuses they become
victims you know and then somebody at
the end you know what they'll say i just
don't understand you i don't know where
to go he doesn't understand me i better
state not i better go back and i better
start watching as i'm working versus
cocky i mean confident versus insulting
i mean is there a fine line you have to
learn we learned that the very specific
line confident means standing up for
what you believe cocky or abusive or
conceited means trying to convince other
people of how terrific you are if you
run your life on your inner signals you
don't have any need to show anybody else
how great you are if you're confident
you just simply do it the basic thing
that neville taught me and a lot of this
is from the teachings of neville uh
neville goddard who died in the 1970s he
he basically said that
all of us have within us this
amazing capacity to manifest and attract
anything that we want into our life so
how we call it what what words that we
use we have to be able to say um you
know in the secret they say you get what
you want you know and what is missing
and what neville said and what what has
come to me and what i got from the i am
discourses and what i get from the new
testament which i read before i did it
is that you you say
i will attract into my life what i am
not what i want and i am capable of
attracting all things that
that the source is capable of attracting
so
that's the difference it's like you get
what you are rather than what you want
so you want to become
you can't go around and ask these divine
beings you know angels whatever you want
to call them who are right here all the
time
you can't ask them to help me out you
have to you have to become like they are
that when you're when you become angelic
when you become a divine being yourself
when you are giving when you are serving
when you are in that place they will
come to you that's what happened to you
in india you then begin to see yourself
in everything that's what the tao de
ching teaches as well they call it your
original nature your original nature is
reverence for all of life gentleness
kindness and service towards others
that's lao tzu 500 years before the
birth of christ saying that's our
original nature yes reverence for all of
life gentleness kindness service towards
other giving offering serving and when
you get to that place where you no
longer have any judgment within you
towards any of god's children that means
no condemnation no criticism no judgment
towards anyone even the osama bin laden
and if enough of us get this message
over if enough of us get out my friend
byron katie says that
to believe that you need what you don't
have is the definition of insanity
to believe that you need
what you don't have
because
you're already here so you've already
proven that you don't need it
so to go around believing that i can't
be
happy fulfilled you know whatever it is
unless i get this stuff that i don't
already have
it's a complete and total illusion it's
a it's a thought that isn't even true
there's no truth to it whatsoever you
don't need anything
and when you get that the irony is
you're no longer you're no longer
attached your your total life is about
it's just about living those virtues how
can i serve how can i be sincere how can
i be gentle how can i be supportive and
thinking like that and that's how i
think now and because of that i'm i'm in
meaning
and being in meaning the times that i
was in ambition
you know
is uh
is delivering more and more and more and
more of what i wanted so much then
and now that i'm not attached to it it's
like i can just be like the i can be
like the cat you know i can just go
about my business and just let it follow
after me so what i say to people who
really want to access the uh
the transition
from
you know from ambition to meaning if
they really want to access it is to get
your thoughts off of yourself
i do it on the radio every every monday
i mean it's like all my questions you
know all the questions are about why
can't i manifest this why can't i have
that this isn't working and so on and my
response back to them all the time over
and over again is uh take what it is
that you would really like to attract
into your life whatever it is whether
it's wealth a job you know
money a nice watch a new car whatever it
is and want it more
for somebody else than you want it for
yourself just just want it more just
think about that and and think about how
much joy it would give you to be able to
put your attention on that and just keep
your thoughts on that you know take your
thoughts off of yourself and start
living the four virtues start being
sincere start being supportive you know
start having this reverence reverence
for for for their life and so on and
just
shift off of what's in it for me you
know and how much am i going to get and
why isn't it here fast enough and how
much why is there shinier than mine and
you know and so on off of that
and and begin to project that and do
that in this world i don't care whether
you're a schoolteacher it does i don't
care if you're a dental hygienist or if
you're a carpenter or you know whatever
it is out there that you are doing if
you can take your attention your if you
want the door to open
if you want the door to open to meeting
then the only way that door is going to
open
is if you understand that you have to
leave your attachment to this grossly
world
of the material things and what's in it
for me and how much am i getting and
shift your energy your thoughts onto how
may i offer how may i serve so this was
something that portia nelson
who i knew who passed away a few years
back
10 years back now she lived up in
seattle and she had um
she was at a seminar
and they were asked to write the uh
autobiography of their life
in five five verses five chapters
so
and they gave them only like cards this
size actually they were smaller than
this
they were three by five cards so write
out chapter one of your life and just go
to where you are today
and um i remember doing this very same
thing but what she wrote was so
brilliant
that i
asked her daughter
if we could put it on public television
which i did on the most recent show and
we made a contribution to porsha's work
so this is what she wrote down
in the
chapter five
of her life chapter one she said i walk
down the street
there's a deep hole in the sidewalk
i fall in
i'm lost
i'm helpless
it isn't my fault
and it takes forever to find a way out
chapter two of my life
i walk down the same street there's a
deep hole in the sidewalk
i pretend i don't see it
i fall in again
i can't believe i'm in the same place
it isn't my fault
it still takes a long time for me to get
out
chapter three of my life
i walk down the same street there's a
deep hole in the sidewalk i see it there
i still fall in
it's a habit
but my eyes are open
i know where i am
and it is my own fault and i get out
immediately
chapter four of my life
i walk down the same street
there's a deep hole in the sidewalk
i walk around it
chapter five of my life
finally
i walk down another street
negrete there are no justified
resentments
this is a very difficult principle for
many people to get but one that i
believe very strongly in
i was
in a group one time
of uh drug addicts and alcoholics
and i was one of the people that was
a sponsor and leading this group
and the sign on the wall
said
there are no justified resentments in
this group
and
what i said to that group that that
night was no matter what anybody says to
you here no matter what kind of uh anger
comes directed towards you
no matter how much hate you may
encounter showing up in your life
there are no
justified
resentments
meaning
that if you carry around resentment
inside of you about anything or about
anyone and i'm talking about the person
that you lent money to and hasn't paid
you back
i'm talking about the person in your
life that you feel was abusive in your
life
i'm talking about the person who walked
out on you and left you for somebody
else
i'm talking about all of the things that
you have justified in your heart and in
your life that you have the right to be
resentful about and i'm suggesting to
you that those resentments will always
end up
harming you and creating in you a sense
of
despair i've often said that
you
no one ever dies from a snake bite
the snake bite will never kill you you
cannot be unbitten once you're bitten
you're bitten
but it's the venom
that continues
to pour through your system
after the bite
that will end up destroying you i used
to say that
before i had children i had eight
theories
about how to raise children
and now i have eight children
and no theories
all right
but one of the things i know about
children
is that
no one likes being told what to do
and this isn't just children this is all
of us
one of my favorite songs is a song from
when i was
back in high school
or give me land lots of land
and the starry skies above
boy you know it
don't fence me in
don't restrict me
don't put
don't put boundaries on me don't tell me
what i can do and what i can't do don't
tell me how to be there don't tell me
what to wear
what to think
don't tell me how to even how to do yoga
don't tell me i don't want to be told
this is the soul speaking always
the soul
is constantly having
a desire
to expand and grow
and anything or anyone that comes into
your life that attempts to do that you
will find yourself
fighting it and reaching back the
obscure outlast the obvious
try to become a little more obscure a
little less interfering a little less
notice me a little less you know one of
the specific kinds of things that you
can do is just as you're about when
somebody else is talking just as you're
about to interject what you've been
thinking about for the whole time
waiting for them to stop talking
just to just stop to bite your tongue
and say tell me more
or that's very interesting i have never
heard that point of view before even if
they totally completely disagree with
everything that you stand for
to be to be willing to listen to being
able to stop practice it i practiced it
when i did these verses of the dao i
practiced it every single day while i
was working on that just staying obscure
and for me that's not always so easy
because of just being recognized
wherever i go and if i saw someone was
about to recognize me i would just put
my head down just walk a little bit past
them like something right now i just
want to be anonymous right now i want to
be obscure the next principle
i call don't die with your music still
in you
and who better to quote than thoreau
right here in concord
when he talked about some of us
hear a different drummer
and we must march to the music that we
hear
but all of you
everybody watching everybody here in
this beautiful parish
all of you have some music playing
and all of you have a heroic mission
there's no accidents in this universe
we all show up here
with a purpose
there's an intelligence that is a part
of everything and everyone and all of us
are connected to it
and
too many of us
are afraid
to listen to that music
and march to it
you out there
i know you have a book you wanted to
ride
i know there's a composition you wanted
to compose i know there's a song you
want to sing someplace
maybe you want to raise horses out in
montana
or maybe you want to open up an ice
cream shop on cape cod who knows what it
may be maybe you just want to travel and
see the world
maybe you want to go
into a relationship with someone but
you've been afraid to but your heart
says it's the right thing to do
all of us feel something
and in leo tolstoy's famous novel the
death of ivan ilich
he asks this question
that would be terrifying to me
he says
as he has his accountant from moscow
lying on his deathbed contemplating the
horror of this question
what if my whole life
has been wrong
i've known what my music is
it's playing right now
as i stand here in front of you with
these cameras and in this place
and as i sit down and write my books and
tell the world what i know are my truths
i feel always completely on purpose and
fulfilled
and no time will i ever come to the end
of my life and say what if my whole life
has been wrong
whoever you are whatever that music is
however distant it may sound however
strange however weird others may
interpret it to be
don't get to the end of your life
and know that you're going to leave
and not have it played yet
don't die with your music still in you
thinking small is what gets great things
done
verse 63
achieve greatness in little things
take on difficulties while they are
still easy
do great things while they are still
small
the sage
the sage
one of my daughter's names the sage does
not attempt anything very big
and thus achieves greatness
greatness comes from being in the moment
here
present
in the now
the sage confronts
difficulties but never
experiences them
this is the idea of thinking
small
and finally
i'd like to see you change from this
thought change from seeing yourself as
separate
to seeing yourself as connected to
everyone and everything
in the universe you can't give away
what you don't have
now it sounds ridiculous okay but it's
more than what meets the ear as you hear
this you can't give away what you don't
have
people who are not good at giving away
love
can't give away love
because they don't have it to give away
if i want to give you a dozen oranges
i can't give you those dozen oranges
unless i go out and pick up 12 oranges
someplace
otherwise all it is is just empty
rhetoric
and the same thing is true of virtually
everything in your life
you can't give away love for others if
you don't have love in here to give away
if what you have in here is contempt if
what you have in here is anger if what
you have in here is fear then these are
the things you're going to be giving
away in your life the second thing that
the ego teaches us is that who i am is
not only what i have but who i am is
what i do what i accomplish
and so
we spend a big hunk of our lives
believing
that the way that we become quote
successful happy fulfilled
self-actualized whatever it might be
is on the basis of what i
accomplish
what my resume looks like
how many promotions i get and so we send
our children off to school
and we ask them to learn
to
identify themselves on how much they get
and what they accomplish your grades
become more important than what it is
that you are studying
what you own what clothes you wear what
labels you have and so on and we become
obsessed with this kind of absurdity
and we this is the false self at work
creative visualization is what we're
talking about here you the
imagery or the image that you have of
anything in your life is really like
mental behavior it's like going out and
practicing if you go out and practice
with a basketball shooting uh free
throws over and over again that's
physical practice imagery is mental
practice it's mental behavior
when you have an image that you can
succeed except at something when you
have an image that you can do it rather
than that you can't do it when you get
into your car and you have an image that
you're going to find a parking place
rather than that there'll be no place to
park so you're not looking for no place
to park you will start acting on the
image that you have very much like you
will start acting on the practice that
you have when you're shooting baskets or
when you're hitting a forehand or or
working on your suit it was thomas
troward i don't know he did some
lectures on mental science way back in
the uh 1907 1908 he was from scotland
and one of the things that he said is
that the
the law of flotation
was not discovered by the contemplation
of the sinking of things
so that you know like before the 15th
and 16th centuries
all of the ships were made out of wood
not because iron wasn't available and
steel wasn't available but because
there was a belief that wood floated so
therefore you had to make ships out of
things that floated that's literally how
the and then someone came along and said
that it has absolutely nothing to do
with what things are made out of it has
to do with the amount of water that is
being dispersed that's that's what
determines whether something will float
or not and i think about that all the
time because it's it's in the
contemplation of what you desire
that you create what it is that you want
to have for yourself it's in your
willingness to contemplate it
and nothing more according to troward
and and
and mental science
so that i think about the wright
brothers you know 100 or so years ago
you know it's like and i said the law of
flying was not discovered by the
contemplation of the staying on the
ground of things so that these were two
people
like for me to figure out how to get an
airplane to fly and my limited knowledge
of all that i would probably have
contemplated the staying on the ground
of things you know like this is what
happened but there's somebody came along
and contemplated the idea that if you
get enough speed going and you have the
right design and you get pressure
underneath something like this and you
get that this thing is going to lift off
off the other somebody had to
contemplate that idea and everybody who
contemplated that it wasn't possible
that it couldn't work was a part of why
flying didn't take place because there
was no new law discovered in the in the
early part of the 20th century
any more than then electricity was
discovered by you know thomas edison or
anyone like that i mean the ability to
have electricity has always been there
somebody has to contemplate so it's like
in your own personal life your
willingness to contemplate yourself as a
person who is capable of attracting into
your life what you want having the kind
of relationships that you want being
able to have abundance where where you
know scarcity always exists all you have
to do is begin the process by having by
being willing to contemplate the
presence of that in your life and i've
always been a person that i can remember
throughout my life as someone who could
contemplate myself being able to do
things that most people couldn't i can
give you a good example when i was when
my mother got us all back together and
we were living in detroit on the east
side of detroit and we got a new
television set it was a black and white
it was a screen about this big it was an
admiral and we had it in our home and it
was like oh my god black and white
television you know uh you remember
uncle milty and all and so on and um
there was a guy that was on tv
his name was steve allen and he was on
the tonight show and um
i was 11 12 13 years old i was born in
1940 so i was 51 or 52
and i used to stay up every night and
watch the tonight show
even though i went to go to school the
next day i it was just something about
that show and you know all of the
characters and box mock and all the
things that the steve allen would do on
it
and i would come down when i would be
talking the next day and i would be
telling my mother and my two brothers
that um
uh when i do the tonight show
um this is what i would say i wouldn't
have said to what what louis and i say
the way it reacted how he reacted that i
would have said this and i used to do
this and my brothers and my mother would
say that's just wayne he's just got he's
just nutty he he thinks he's on the
tonight show he thinks he's going to do
the tonight show and i would go up into
my room at uh you know on this little
tiny house that we lived in a little
two-bedroom house that uh five of us
lived in because my mother remarried and
um and i would just i would see myself
doing the tonight show i would just
practice it and steve allen became
someone that i was really an amateur
well you know fast forward uh i don't
know 30 years or whatever
so and that's uh and i've written a book
uh your erroneous zones and the the
tonight show calls and they asked me if
i would like to come on
so i do my first uh stint on the tonight
show i did the show like 37 times over a
period of three or four years with all
these different hosts but johnny carson
was on and the
the first guest on the very first show
when i did the show was uh was steve
allen and
it was like something clicked in me that
i had contemplated that as a child i had
always had a knowing and i can remember
sitting there talking to johnny about
this thing that you know and steve allen
was sitting there right next to me and
we were talking about that kind of so
that by putting my attention on
something it wasn't some deliberate
thing that i was doing you know when i
was 11 or 12 years old that was
designating that i was going to be a
person who was going to be uh appearing
on talk shows 30 years from now it was
just an awareness to a willingness to
contemplate
to contemplate myself in that kind of a
place and i think the power of
contemplation is the thing that most
people haven't harnessed yet and when we
do when you harness it in your life
there's absolutely no limit to what you
can attract into your life if you
absolutely stay focused on what it is
that you know you're going to manifest
and attract you're not going to do it in
in your time you know jackson brown
sings a song it says and creation
reveals its secrets by and by i mean you
can't push the river you can't it's all
done in divine time but it will show it
will show
it it will manifest it will attract
itself and i'm never surprised any
longer about anything that i put my
thoughts on that i can attract it into
my life i just absolutely know that law
of attraction and that it absolutely
works the way to this higher place
within ourselves
is understanding two very important
words
these words are the basis for uh
a children's book that i've just done
called i am why two little words mean so
much
any moms right here in the front you a
mom here would you like to have this for
your baby
you're welcome god bless you namaste
so
let me just take you back
for a few moments here
back
back before lao tzu
now lao tzu was here on this planet at
the time of the warring states in china
in 500 bc
approximately the same time that the
bhagavad-gita
was also being created in india
the song of the lord
800 years eight centuries
before that
thirteen hundred years before the birth
of christ
comes
one of the most ancient if not the most
uh ancient spiritual texts extent on the
pr on the planet today
it's called the torah
the first five books of the old
testament
in the second book of the torah
exodus
moses
is
well you know the story of moses but if
you don't let me refresh you
at the time of uh
moses's birth the pharaoh
who had held so many of the israelites
captive and enslaved had ordered that
all male babies to be born
of uh
from israelite mothers because he had
heard that there was someone coming
that could be a danger to his uh power
he ordered that all male babies be be
executed
well
moses's mother
gave birth and she just couldn't stand
the idea of this baby being killed by
the soldiers
so she wrapped him up in a blanket
and put him in a basket
must have been waterproof
and floated him down the nile
moses this little baby was discovered
by
a woman
who um
captured him picked them up and fell so
in love with him that she decided to
raise him as her own
it turns out that this was the daughter
of the pharaoh
so
moses grandfather is the pharaoh who has
ordered him to be killed but he doesn't
know this
at about the age of 18
uh moses gets into a fight
and with one of the people one of the
soldiers who is
trying to
be uh
trying to actually punish and abs and
kill one of the israelites and so moses
fights him and kills him
and has to run away because he knows
what his punishment will be
he runs away
to the sinai
and for the next 40 years he is a
shepherd he marries a woman named zepara
they have all of these children he's a
shepherd he's out wandering about
according to this ancient text
one day
he comes across a bush a burning bush
but the bush is not being consumed it is
just continuing to burn
and he looks at this and suddenly the
bush begins to speak and as legend tells
us this is god
speaking to moses
and saying to moses
i have
i have some instructions for you
i
i'll give it to you the way it is
written
i just love this
so god calls out to moses from this bush
and says moses moses
and moses responds with the words here i
am this is the first words he speaks to
god
do not come closer he said take your
sandals off your feet for the place
where you are standing is holy ground
then he continues i am the god of your
father the god of abraham the god of
isaac the god of jacob moses hid his
face because he was afraid to look at
god
so god gives him this instruction you
are to go and free the people of israel
so moses says to god
who am i
that i should go to pharaoh and that i
should bring the israelites out of egypt
he answered
i will certainly be with you and this
will be the sign to you that i have sent
you when you bring the people out of
egypt you will all worship god at this
mountain
then moses asked god if i go to the
israelites and say to them the god of
your fathers has sent me to you and they
ask me what is his name
what shall i tell them
now the only place in all the spiritual
texts where god gives his name
is right here in this passage same name
that you have
god replies to moses i am
that
i am
this is what you are to say to the
israelites i am has sent me to you
god also said to moses say this to the
israelites
yahweh the god of your fathers the god
of abraham and this is my name forever
this is how i am to be remembered in
every generation to come
which is our generation
all right
so
the name of god
is i am
that
i am
now
every time
you use the name
i am
you are using the name of god
how do you use this name
do you say
i am sick
many of you know that i have been
diagnosed with leukemia
and i generally start out my talks by
saying i am
well
i am perfect health
i am that
i am
that is my affirmation
that is how i live that is how i breathe
that is how i believe
now
in the book of joel
there's a line
that says
let the weak man say
i am
strong
now what i want
one of the things that i want to leave
you with here and the time that i have
with you today
is for you to become conscious of how
you use this term i am
i have a cd
along with my friend james twyman
that is um
what they did with this is it comes from
the moses code which is a book i
encourage you to look at by james twyman
and what they did is they took the sound
in hebrew
of the letters that mean i am that i am
supposedly this is what god said to
moses
and they have
associated the sound with what those
letters meant back thirteen hundred
years before the birth of christ or
three thousand three hundred years ago
and come up with the sound
the sound is a meditation that i do
every day
and what i recommend that you do
you want this don't you
oh you have it oh you have it great all
right all right you got it
so what i encourage you to do in terms
of manifesting before i get into the
principles
is
to take out a piece of paper sometime
when you're at home and it's
it sounds like a silly thing to do but i
want you to do it i want you to write at
the top of that page the word that
t-h-a-t that
okay
and under that
heading
whatever it is that you would like to
attract or manifest into your life
i would like you to just write that down
all right so if it's a job that you want
if it's a relationship that you want if
it's a
healing that you want if it's a
abundance that you want to attract into
your life whatever it is
just place it underneath that
and come to a place in your life
where it is spoken about in the book of
romans in the new testament
he calls those things which do not exist
as though they
did
you must be able to get to this place in
your life
where you don't use the evidence of your
senses
what your eyes tell you what your ears
tell you
what your stomach tells you
what you see written down what the
internet tells you
you want to be able to be in a place
where you are living from the end as if
what you would like to manifest is
already there
to make a present a future dream a
present fact you must assume the feeling
of that wish as already being fulfilled
what does spiritual film mean to you and
and
what are your
most favorite films about transformation
well aside from europe yeah
yes
i love
you know
one of my very favorite movies was just
recently a uh a spiritual cinema uh
monthly selection whatever it was it was
called deja vu yes with vanessa redgrave
yeah
that that film just blew me away yeah i
mean
you know any film that has chase scenes
in it or has violence in it or guns in
it and so on i'm just i i don't really
turn off i just i don't even go to them
but um like that film got me really
thinking about the possibilities if any
of you haven't seen the wonderment of a
great film like that is that you begin
to think oh there's this possibility
which yeah that all you know that all
things are possible and you can make
anything happen do you think that films
can be used for social social change oh
absolutely see one of the reasons i did
it did this film the the shift yeah was
because i you know i've heard that uh 10
percent of the people in this guy in our
country
buy um almost 100 of the book something
like 97 98 percent of the books which
means that approximately 85 to 90
percent of the people never buy never
buy a book and i've written lots and
lots of books but those
but those same 90
right those those same 90 of the people
um
they go to the movies
they go to the movies so i thought well
i and i remember because it was
brilliantly done because i remember
seeing the promotion
on the internet for months and or maybe
maybe a year prior to to it coming out
it was always it was very intriguing and
well there's just great people in it
michael bergeon is a great director and
porsche de rossi i mean
and uh michael delaway's dom de louisia
all of the people in this film are when
i was asked to do the film i did the
film at the age of 68 and which meant
taking on a whole new career
um because i don't take direction well
and i speak like i'm speaking now in
front of an audience i don't use notes
right but when you do a film as you know
doing it being having learned films you
do the same thing over and over and over
and over again
and i just decided that this was
something that i could do i just uh one
of the excuses i didn't want to use is
i'm too old to learn this so you can't
teach an old dog new tricks you can
teach an old dog anything you know and
so
i'm sure you were still spontaneous or
you know anyway well i insisted that it
be professionally done and i didn't work
because i've seen a lot of those a lot
of the movies that are called spiritual
movies but the quality the quality is
just not there and there's people trying
to be actors and they're not and so on
um i wanted it to be a polished
professional film good for you and my
goal was to have 10 million people watch
it and i and i know that that will
happen and what will happen once you see
10 million in america is pi do you
remember pi when you were in geometry
3.1416 if you can get
3.1416 percent of a population to align
all the rest all the rest fall into
places
they all begin to align so for me if 10
million people watch the shift we can
make a shift not only in our country but
on our planet as well and that's why i'm
happy to have the film as part of
spiritual cinema because it's another
whole bunch of thousands of people who
watch it tell us inspired the whole
spiritual cinema circle
you know fan base they've they're
totally turned on by the film so that's
wonderful that's great what films do you
think have made a positive impact on
society
well i remember um
what was the
the who's the guy that ran all the way
across the country what was uh oh first
gump forrest gump
forrest gump was one of those kind of
films that made people look at uh
at people who we call special needs and
and see the beauty and see the the joy
in them um i think the film about uh
that what tom hanks was in uh about the
d-day
um oh yeah saving private ryan yes i
think
that that film transformed my brother's
life my brother dave was in vietnam was
a bronze star winner and saw
saw such horrible horrible violence he
was a medic there and he saw hundreds
and hundreds of people and he had never
talked about it for um for 30 40 years
never talked about it he was just so
bogged up inside you couldn't get a word
out of him he now has parkinson's
disease and
um and so many of those people of that
generation weren't allowed to really
speak about you
yeah know what it's like yeah that's
what it's like i think the film ghost
was uh was one of those films that
really you know deeply and profoundly uh
touched me in in terms of looking at
um when it opened window the other side
guidance from the other side yeah those
kinds of things yes
lots more lots more yeah
so what kind of films do you think young
people should see and why
well i think young people should see
films that um
i don't like to use the word should but
i i yeah
yeah but i think young people
can can benefit greatly by uh
by films that that give them
sort of an expanded view of of of what
is possible in the world instead of so
much of what we think young people want
to see which is
you know a lot of silliness and
a lot of violence yeah and and a lot of
obscenity and so on um
and also emptying you know these empty
films it's like there's so much big
something happening but there's not you
know you you cut you look under the
surface and there's nothing going on i
get letters from people who've seen the
shift um and they said they just had it
on in their home and the
you know their teenagers will come in
and they'll say what are you watching
and all this is not and then before you
know it
they're hooked yeah they're hooked and
they're watching it they're telling
other people about it as well
so um i think i think if it can just
expand your consciousness and just and i
think film can can make a huge
difference in in transforming the world
i really do yeah we've kind of asked
answered this question and you've sort
of made this film but i'm going to ask
it anyway
if time money or talent or an obstacle
what kind of movie would you like to
make
if you go got to do it again
and you had every everything at your
disposal now having made a film you know
the opportunity that that is
there was there were no obstacles the
money wasn't an obstacle and time wasn't
and
i just did we just did what we wanted to
do
and um and i think this film uh and
maybe perhaps a follow-up to it yeah
maybe following the characters or
something um is uh
i would just like to make a film that
can can make make the shift because
we've got to we've got to make the shift
well this has been just delightful i
could speak to you forever but i think
we've run out of time thank you so much
i was such a admirer of your grandfather
oh thank you such a great moment why i
say thank you because i'm responsible
i remember reading islands in the stream
yeah and a lot of people uh you know one
of the lines that he had in there uh a
man had just been uh
he just found out that his son had been
killed in the in the war in uh in spain
um and he that night was out dancing
and someone said to him how can you be
dancing when you just found out that
news and i've never forgotten this he
said
he said i decided that sooner or later i
would have to get over this or it would
kill me
and he said i just picked sooner and i
learned that from your grandfather yeah
pick sooner pick center yeah
giving up your personal history
and i learned it from a man named carlos
castaneda who once said that
one day he said i finally realized that
i no longer needed a personal history
and just like drinking he said i gave it
up and that and only that has made all
the difference in the world
you know the nice thing about giving up
your personal history
is that if you don't have a story
you don't have to live up to it
all of us have these bags
of manure that we carry around with us
called our past and the people who have
done things to us and the events and the
circumstances all of this stuff that we
use and we bond to and we bond ourselves
to these wounds of our past and we
identify ourselves on the basis of these
wounds and every once in a while we set
it down and we reach in there and we
smear it all over ourselves
and then we wonder why does my life
smell so bad i don't understand this
when in fact
the now
this moment merging yourself into the
now means that you may have been in a
relationship i had a woman from holland
who came over to see me whose husband
had left her after 25 years she had four
children and she just had been on the
verge of suicide and she was losing
weight and she was depressed and she was
taking all kinds of drugs for it and she
was getting sicker and sicker because
she just couldn't get over it and she
came to a book signing that i was doing
at a bookstore down in florida
and she said you've got to say something
to me
you've got to say something to me
that will help me
to get over this
and i told her this line i said give up
your personal history
merge yourself here now into this moment
and those 25 years are something if you
want to understand how to do it think of
your past
as
oh this hat
and this is your past
now you can't just set this thing down
over here
and walk away from it and give up your
personal history because
you'll always have it there to look back
at what you do is you pick up your
past
and you embrace it
you understand it you accept it as i had
to go through these things that i had to
go through in order for me to get to
this place today and the evidence for
that is that i did you don't need any
more evidence you did
and then
you
toss it
you toss it
you embrace it and you toss it and you
merge into the now
by giving up
your attachment and some of you have
heard me use the metaphor of the wake
alan watts talked about the wake is not
what drives the boat the wake is just a
trail that is left behind that's all it
is and so is the wake of your life
and the wake doesn't make the boat go
and neither does the wake of your life
the reason why your life is going in the
direction that it is
the wake is a trail that is left behind
and it's an illusion to believe that it
is the cause
of your suffering or your struggles or
your difficulty
give it up
let it go embrace it understand it get
help doing that if you must
and then move into the now
the next principle i call
it's from a line of uh albert einstein
he said you can't solve a problem
with the same mind
that created it
in order to work at solving these things
called problems in your life you have to
change your mind it is your mind where
they live it is your mind that created
them they there is where you experience
them they're all illusions you must
change your mind literally rewrite your
agreement with reality
one of the things i had said earlier is
that one of the most difficult things to
do in the world is to
admit that you were wrong
admitting that you were wrong
is nothing more
than saying
i have been making choices with my mind
that have created things in my life that
are not working
and i no longer intend to continue
making those choices
i was wrong
you don't have to make a declaration of
it you don't have to go out and feel
guilty about it you just simply say it
didn't work
the relationship that i was in before i
behaved in these ways i didn't realize
that it wasn't working for me now i do
and this is where i choose to be now
the secret of a successful relationship
is
to me
understanding that you put your
attention and your energy in a person
on what you love rather than what you
don't love robert frost said it so
beautifully we love the things we love
for what they are
for what they are not for what they
ought to be not for what they used to be
but for what they are so when you look
into the eyes of a person you're in a
relationship with whether it's your
children you catch them doing things
right as much as you possibly can that's
oftentimes takes a lot of hunting but
you'll find it
and when you
think that my relationship isn't working
remember it's in my mind what am i
thinking about that person
and if i could just change my mind
and put my thoughts on what i love about
this person and keep them there that
makes the relationship flourish and
there are people who go through their
entire relationship history with no
anger no hatred
no bitterness and only love
the next principle
is i call it treating yourself
as if you already were
what you would like to become
in other words you get out in front of
your life
and you see yourself
as
having already what you know you'd like
to have and deserve to have my children
know how to do this perfectly i have a
daughter who wanted a prom dress
and the prom dress was way outside the
budget that i thought a prom dress
should be uh well i thought a prom dress
shouldn't cost over 20 so i do have a
problem huh
but
i
upped it to somewhere around 250 to i
don't know how much whatever to me it
was still more than i paid for my first
house okay uh
but anyway she called and said dad this
is the only prom desk i could with this
is the i've got to wear this promise if
i don't wear this prom desk it's just on
and on and on with this uh wonderful you
know i've got a i saw a wonderful book
about how to raise teenage daughters
the title of it is get out of my life
but first drive me and cheryl to the
mall all right that's a that's the
actual title it's a good book
and so i told serena i said it's just
beyond the budget i've got a certain
amount of money that i'm willing to put
for it and she said but i've already
seen myself wearing it i've already
tried it on i have a picture of myself
in the dress in my living room and i've
already showed it to the guy who was
taking me to the prom i mean it was this
whole thing about and she already saw
herself in it i said well if you see
yourself in it then you're going to have
to also see yourself as earning the
difference between what i'm willing to
pay
and she drew up a contract she went out
to the computer and on the background of
the computer you know where they have
these little background things they put
on there was 500 pictures of the dress
all right
and she signed a contract and said i'll
babysit i'll do this i'll do that and i
will pay the difference and she did and
she wore the dress because she
understood that you treat yourself as if
you already are what you'd like to
become there's a genius in you you have
to treat yourself as if you already were
that genius there's something you're
completely capable of see yourself as
already there then you'll act upon those
thoughts because the ancestor to every
action said emerson is a thought
the next principle is called treasuring
your divinity
treasuring your divinity there's a
wonderful observation
that i saw
from uh
from emerson
in self-reliance
it's about trusting your divinity
knowing that you are connected to your
source
knowing that you are a divine creation
and that there are no accidents
he said a man should learn to detect and
watch that gleam of light
which flashes across his mind from
within
more than the luster of the firmament of
bards and sages
yet he dismisses without notice his own
thought
because it's his own
in every work of genius
we recognize our own rejected thoughts
they come back to us with a certain
alienated majesty
we often reject our thoughts and we see
the things that we think of as grand and
as genius and we reject them because
they're our own
treasuring our divinity instead of being
terrified of it knowing that i am always
connected to my source there is no way
that i cannot because it is in you and i
am in you and you are in me and you can
never be separated from it there is no
place that this source is not
it grows everybody's fingernails it
beats everybody's hearts it digests
everybody's foods it opens all the
flowers and you're always connected to
it
and finally
the last principle
i call
wisdom is avoiding all thoughts which
weaken you
you know every thought has an energy
just like everything else in the
universe and if you have a thought of
shame
it will weaken your muscles and what is
your heart but a muscle
if you raise a child who believe in
shame and feel ashamed of themselves
every time they think that shameful
thought
they will be weakened
and if you have a thought of fear and if
you have a thought of stress and you
have a thought of anguish and anxiety
all of these thoughts and many more
are the thoughts that will always weaken
you
when you are having a thought that you
know is it disempowering you
shift it shift it to one that is
empowering rather than disempowering
and the thoughts that empower our
thoughts of neutrality and willingness
and love
and ultimately thoughts of divinity
and when you see a troubled person
who is out there struggling
at the highest level of unity
consciousness or god consciousness or
spiritual consciousness
you recognize yourself
in all that you see
there but for the grace of god go i
and i am connected to that person
changing your thoughts
i appeared on the tonight show many
years ago
several times quite a few times
and i remember coming home from the
tonight show and i was walking along the
beach and they had taped the show the
night before
and i was out for a walk and a woman who
lived in
the northeast
stopped me and she said didn't i see you
last night on the how could you be here
i said well i flew the red eye and i was
walking along and
she said you know we're moving down here
she said
what are the people like here what's it
like
and i said to her i said well what are
they like where you live she said well
she said i i live in a very big city and
she said they're very pushy
and people are not very kind and they
don't have time for you and
she said uh it's really not very
pleasant she said that's one of the
reasons i'm leaving there
i said well that's pretty much what
you're going to find here
that's basically what the people are
like here
on the way back on the same day someone
else who had seen me the night before on
the tonight show
who had lived in the midwest
stopped me and asked me almost the same
question she said you live here i said
yes she said well my husband and i are
moving here and we're looking for a
school she said what are the people like
here what's it like here
i said what are they like in chicago
where you live she said oh she said it's
the midwest she said people are very
friendly they're open they open their
homes to you they're very loving they're
very kind she said it's a wonderful
place she said i love that i'm going to
really miss that i said
that's pretty much
what you're going to find here
it's what you expect it's what you think
about
that expands it's what emerson taught us
the ancestor to every action
is a thought change your thoughts
and you change your world change your
expectations
and you change around what you begin to
manifest and see showing up in your life
thank you very much
the ego is not worth defending
and and we all spend a lot of our time
defending this thing that says well you
know i am what i do have and i have to
get more things and if i don't have as
much as they do then they're gonna and
we go through our lives doing all of
this stuff and what it does is it brings
us to a point where we no longer have
something or our reputation is gone or
taken away from us or somebody steals it
and what happens to us or when we retire
or you know any and i no longer can do
things so now people get over a certain
age and they just feel like you know
i've declined and so on there's nothing
in the dna that says you have to decline
ever in your life you don't have to
decline in your dna is over six hundred
thousand why do we have it though why do
we have it we have it because it works
it works to get getting ourselves
believing that we're better than other
people instead of just allowing
ourselves to be free and that's it's
like it's like taoism the dow teaches us
to like unpeel the onion on peel layers
to get to that the essence of the dao is
emptiness getting to that place of
emptiness that's like the supreme place
to get to where you just empty of all of
that and then you're free and then guess
what all of the things that you wanted
so desperately when you were so ego
dominated before begin to show up
in larger and larger and larger amounts
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some amazing louise hey motivation
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there many times or
you've read or
listened on the tapes that loving
yourself
is the most powerful thing we can do
then everything flows
everything flows beautifully